do you remember that container ship the
everg given that got stuck in the sez
Canal back in 2021 the final report into
what happened came out a few months ago
as I record this and there were a lot of
things that went wrong it was traveling
too fast there were Communications
problems between the crew and the local
pilots and there was the bank effect
there are two ways to learn what that is
you can get the theoretical explanation
that big ships get suck to the side
walls by pressure differences when
traveling at speed along canals but if
that seems a bit abstract you can learn
it Hands-On because this is the port
iava ship handling research and Training
Center in the north of Poland and this
is one of the places where the folks who
steer those big ships learn how to do it
just to be clear I'm not getting a full
training course that takes days and
includes a huge amount of theory work
and study as well I'm just going to
drive a miniature container ship for a
lap round the lake and hopefully not get
it stuck in the soz
canal we have started our training activ
AC ity in 1980 in '90s we have moved
from the old Lake towards this one and
practically first training here was
realized in
1991 more or less 30 years ago we are
performing training in ship handling we
have a lot of different mockups
presenting different waterways
everything was built using exactly the
same scale 1 to 24 deep Waters shallow
waters different rest restrictions
Rivers canals and what is more important
of course ship models permission to come
aboard
granted okay this is bigger than I
thought it was going to be yeah it's one
of the biggest in the world 400 m ship
400 m scale down one in 24 that's still
16 and2 that's okay this is big cool we
can proceed dead slow ahead so dead slow
ahead yeah and Steady As She Goes
forward I assume that means just keep it
going straight okay these are the tagbo
simulators I don't feel guilty about you
um you taking the controls I'd be on tug
boats coming out I was meant to be
asking all sorts of questions here and
I'm just slightly nervous about driving
a tiny boat it's not a tiny boat it's a
400 m container ship yeah so you have
controls there that simulate the effect
of tugs on right for you may make a
rather hard to Port hard to Port oh I
don't know why but I thought I was going
to spin that like the wheel of a pirate
ship and it it's just a yeah all right
so what's our plan now okay so now we
can go through the lock if you like yeah
absolutely basically we go that
direction south of the island I feel
like I need to go left here yeah make it
Port Port not left we have had you know
our history more than 6,000 Pilots
Masters and chief officers from more
than 50 countries in average 220
230 a year we have beginners but we have
also very experienced Masters because
lock is very shallow yeah we will have
only 2 cm of water under kill if we have
too high speed we touch the bottom So
the faster I go in shallow water the
more the boat is going to get down more
more Squad you have yeah we have to come
in the line with the lock oh we do that
more time we have to apply any
correction if necessary that is such a
tight spot to navigate hard to starboard
for while starboard
starbard the minute I feel like I've got
this it's all going to fall apart uh mid
chips yes please yeah and star Y and mid
chips y oh I think I've overcorrected
that there's some very strong work being
done by the tugboats here thank you we
have no clearance here I feel like
starboard slightly yeah starboard 20
starboard
20 I can't see how close we are there
did we clear that yes I think we cleared
that yes again solid tugbo work uh mid
chips surely starb 20 okay the basic
training program takes 5 days lineer
scale 1 to 24 means that time scale is
equal to more S 5 it means everything
happens five times faster than in
reality and feeling for a ship may be
affected it is disadvantage but from
other hand 5 days of training will
correspond to 25 days of training in
reality hard to starboard hard to
starboard more the Helmsman than the
captain at this point Thank you hard to
Port again hard to Port left hand down a
bit yeah okay I think we can make a half
ahead half
aead we are clear of the lock
yeah Full Ahead Full
Ahead did I need to slam that forward so
dramatically absolutely not but our
first models were really very simple
nothing inside just wheel engine
Telegraph and that's it and step by step
we have started to add different
facilities we have electronic navigation
it means very precise GPS system which
allows to measure a given ship model
trajectory with Precision equal to 1
maybe 2 cm suddenly the nerves have
gone open uh open ocean open Lake
starboard 10 starboard 10 because you've
got to cancel out what you've just given
it right we're still going quite
strongly to Port just because that input
from the wind AG ago and the wind the
wind yeah okay I'm amazed how much the
wind is affecting this you have to
imagine that such a ship fully loaded
has about 20,000 square m of the windage
area everything during exercises is
measured sent towards classroom and in
case of problems we can discuss step by
step and we can show where mistakes were
made oh so I got distracted by a
corant current especially in case of
shallow water is a big problem it means
we have current generators this current
velocity can be changed according to our
needs
I thought we hit something that oh we
did that's that's me sorry no problem
it's not like this thing has rear view
mirrors oh okay half ahead half ahead
we're sailing a massive container ship
down the SE Canal do I need to put a
little bit of Rudder in here yeah it's
fine now we have to go behind Vera right
you can make a port 10 Port 10 got it I
think we're clearing the red Bo mid chip
mid
chip no it's clear okay Port 20 Port 20
mid chips mid chips okay and a Full
Ahead Full Ahead okay starbard 20 starbo
20 cuz we' got to ease out the then you
will start feeling the bunk effect from
the
starbo so it feels like I could go
midships now we should just go straight
down the middle of this canal except the
bunk effect you see bow is coming out it
means the repulsion Force
now you have to make stard hard
starboard go yeah I'm being sucked
towards the port wall I'm putting full
right lock on here mid ships mid ships
okay you see again it's coming y it is
so we have to make hard to starboard
hard to Star yeah if I don't do hard to
Star you have hit this one absolutely
going to ram that if we're not careful
yeah that's so powerful you yeah H yeah
St hard to Star it I was mid ships we
should have been going straight ahead
and I think I have to help with the
you're going to have to help with that I
should have done that
earlier everybody
down clear oh cleared mid ship hard to
Port hard to
Port we were lucky one inle that was
that was more luck than good judgment
that was our research is focused on ship
handling it means interaction forces and
autonomous ships we have started ration
of research programs three or four years
ago because autonomous ships would be
really very popular we need at least 10
ships lengths yeah to stop the ship and
10 ships lengths and that Harbor is here
I definitely need to put some port in
yes hard hard to Port okay everything in
case of our training center is realized
in real conditions you can feel very
well wind you can feel very well current
and everything what deals with weather
conditions such a situation does not
happen in case when using computer
simulators and especially Pilots coming
to our training center for training
prefer very often to use models instead
of computer simulation every driver's
Instinct in me is going I just slam it
in reverse take it round it'll be fine
no it won't that's not how this works
collisions really occur at the training
CER the main difference regarding
computers and our models is in computers
in case of problems you can switch off
everything and you can restart
everything that's okay in the case of
our Clinic Center the only one thing to
do is to call technical staff for rescue
tax and quite often our models are sent
directly from the training center to our
Shipyard for different repairing works
and this psychological effect influences
very much level of Education people
realize everything a little bit
differently When comparing with computer
simulators all right we are home that
was a privilege thank you very very much
I know very few people get problem here
every instructor can do that very
easily
there is one thing I forgot to ask can
can can I push the whistle button
please thank
you